señalamientos cruzados por la
destrucción de La Represa de cacofca
mientras los habitantes de gersón dejan
atrás sus casas inundadas por la
explosión que provocó el desborde de La
Represa las autoridades en ambos bandos
de la guerra se culpan mutuamente desde
kiev el presidente ucraniano voló de
mirzalenski culpó a las tropas rusas de
ecocidio y calificó la explosión de la
presa como una bomba Ambiental de
destrucción masiva todo el mundo sabrá
sobre este crimen de guerra ruso El
crimen del ecocidio tal destrucción
deliberada por parte de los ocupantes
rusos de La Represa y otras estructuras
de la central hidroeléctrica de jacobca
es una bomba Ambiental de destrucción
masiva por el bien de la propia
seguridad el mundo debería Mostrar ahora
que Rusia no puede salirse con la suya
con tal terror Mientras tanto en una
sesión del Consejo de Seguridad el
enviado de Rusia al organismo señaló que
el incidente sería un Sabotaje interno
propiciado por autoridades ucranianas
el Sabotaje deliberado emprendió porque
contra una instalación de
infraestructura crítica es
extremadamente peligroso y puede
clasificarse esencialmente como un
crimen de guerra o un acto de terrorismo
las altas esferas en el kremlin y en
kiev continúan señalándose por la
destrucción en territorio ucraniano y
mientras se encuentran al culpable los
habitantes de las ciudades afectadas
tienen que huir de sus hogares para no
ser un número más en la guerra